Good morning Hank, it's Monday, January 8th.
Sarah and I are about to drive out of Asheville,
on our way to Birmingham, Alabama.
I know you're gonna be here soon, but in the
meantime I thought you should enjoy how pretty
it is. We're going down the dirt road on the
way to the other dirt road that leads away
from Mom's house. And Dad's house! Sorry Dad,
geez.
I would like to congratulate you on successfully
completing the Strawberry Hill challenge,
except that you didn't complete it! Drinking
Sutter Home wine when you've been challenged
to drink Strawberry Hill is like slow dancing
with Teddy Ruxpin when you've been challenged
to wrestle a grizzly bear. Sutter Home may
be terrible, but at least it's derived from
grapes.
Strawberry Hill isn't made out of grapes.
It's made out of strawberries. Just kidding,
it's made out of apple wine, malt, red dye,
and the fires of hell.
Hank, as you know, I had surgery on my mouth
a few weeks ago. After they sewed my gum back
into my mouth, my mouth tasted like cement
and blood and burnt meat. And you know how
after any dental procedure they make you drink
that, like, green, gross, minty alcoholy stuff
and then spit? Strawberry Hill tast-
*achoo* (whispers) That was the Yeti!
Strawberry Hill tastes exactly like that spit.
Do you think I'm funny? Am I trying too hard?
When? The whole time? Teddy Ruxpin? It's just
you get that way around the camera.
So Hank, today is a very significant day,
and I'll tell you why. It's January 8th and
the first draft of my new novel is due on
January 21st. Now, I'm not a mathematician,
but I know a couple, so I called Daniel Biss
and he told me that January 21st is only 13
days away.
Aside from the problem of actually finishing
the book, which is, admittedly, a pretty serious
problem, there's the problem that it doesn't
have a title. I would feel a lot better if
I actually had a title for the novel so that
I could say, you know, in ten days I have
to turn in the first draft of my new novel,
The Babysitter's Club 26: Claudia's Sad Goodbye.
I've been thinking of using either Shakespeare
or the Bible. You've got a lot of great Shakespearean
titles over the years, like: Infinite Jest,
The Dogs of War, Brave New World, In Cold
Blood. And there are also a lot of great Bible
titles like: East of Eden, Song of Solomon,
or Rich Dad Poor Dad. Of course in the Biblical
version of Rich Dad Poor Dad, rich dad gets
turned into a pillar of salt and, uh, poor
dad is exalted above all others. Anyway Hank,
I'm hopeful you'll be able to come up with
a title for me.
Project idea: the Brotherhood 2.0 Book Club.
I'll read a book you suggest if you read a
book I suggest. My first suggestion? Either
"What is the What," by Dave Eggers or "We
Wish to Inform You That Tomorrow We Will be
Killed With Our Families," by Philip Gourevitch.